when I sat down with the cast of Suicide
Squad now here's the deal
Margot Robbie showed up on set with a
tattoo gun so everybody thought it would
be a great bonding experience to get
some ink well hold on
almost everybody come on get something
better
why didn't you get a squad tattoo man
I'm a grown-ass man I'm a grown-ass man
Margeaux comes bounding in to work with
all of her 24 year old glory as guys
guys I got a tattoo gun I got a tattoo
gun we're all getting tattoos y'all
Joker's must be crazy just about
everyone else was in on the deal
Margeaux with her new tattoo gun doing
ankles arms even toes I mean I tattooed
her toes then she got dude mine as well
that's Q something fun make sure what I
like a four-year-old would throw and you
stick it on your fridge that's kind of
what my another person who opted out
jared leto
all of that chit chats gonna get checked
he was way too busy being the Joker I
felt a tremendous amount of pressure or
terror you may call it there have been
such unforgettable performances Jack
Nicholson Heath Ledger saves our Amero
it really encouraged me to work that
much harder I see everything
speaking of characters to live up to
Viola Davis who plays team leader Amanda
Waller will always have Annalise Keating
who is tougher Amanda Waller or your
character on how to get away with murder
Amanda Waller with Wolfe and Elise is
behind I don't know why Annalise can
bend people's minds around right she can
but she drinks too much vodka
I love Biola I do I do
great that was hilarious had so much fun
with that cast margot robbie will be the
breakout star of this movie and listen
prepare yourself okay because harley
quinn will be everywhere parents are you
ready for halloween well then get ready
I don't think the rebel oh boy
you